Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's Penne Honey, das ist ein Nudelgericht, das extrem schnell geht und einfach jedem schmeckt.
Das ist eine Soße aus Sahne, Honig, Senf und ein paar Gewürzen.
Und wie gesagt es geht echt fix und ich glaube ihr werdet das auch sehr häufig nachmachen!
Deswegen gehe ich jetzt direkt rüber zum Herd und ich habe hier die Zwiebeln schon vorgeschnitten.
Ich möchte das Video um ehrlich zu sein kurz halten weil das einfach ein knackiges Rezept ist!
Oh, vorher nehme ich mir natürlich Rapsöl, geb das in die beschichtete Pfanne
und geb da die schon geschnittenen Zwiebeln rein.
Direkt im Anschluss geben wir dann Hähnchenbrust dazu,
die habe ich vorab in mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten.
Salzen und pfeffern und dann nur ganz kurz mit anbraten.
So und jetzt kommen die Gewürze noch an die Reihe, die weiteren Gewürze.
Und zwar habe ich hier Curry, edelsüßes Paprikapulver, Oregano und ein bisschen Chili aber nur ein bisschen.
Und das gebe ich jetzt mit dazu und fülle das Ganze dann mit Sahne auf.
Jetzt habe ich alles gut umgerührt und hab das einmal aufkochen lassen und an der Stelle einmal
Deckel drauf und so lange köcheln lassen, bis die Hähnchenbrust gar ist.
Jetzt habe ich sie ja sehr klein geschnitten, deswegen dauert das bei mir so um die 10min
und gelegentlich immer mal wieder umrühren. Und in der Zwischenzeit gare ich schon mal Penne.
Es ist ja Penne Honey, ihr könnt natürlich auch andere Nudeln nehmen, ist gar kein Thema.
So das Hähnchen ist gar. Jetzt schalte ich den Herd einmal aus und geb jetzt Senf und Honig dazu
und rühre das noch mal schön ein.
Und dann ist das ganze Gericht auch schon fertig, die Nudeln sind nämlich auch schon gar
und die rühre ich gleich einfach mit in die Soße. Und ich liebe das, wenn da so viel Soße ist!
(H: Jaa, ich auch!)
Ja und das eben nicht so trocken ist
und genauso ist das!
(H: Mein Geschmack Kiki!)
Mmmh, lecker!
(H: *lacht*)
Unbedingt nachkochen, ihr werdet es nicht bereuen!
Und ich glaube das ist was für die ganze Familie und das Beste ist: das hat nur 15min gedauert!
15 Minuten eurer Zeit und-
(H: Ich liebe deine schnellen Rezepte!)
Ja, schnelle Rezepte, die lecker sind, wer liebt es nicht?
Und ich mache dazu jetzt auch noch gleich schnellen Salat und dann sind wir rundum glücklich!
Schaut gerne in die Videobeschreibung, da stehen nämlich erstens die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
und zweitens unser Instagram Account! Ihr müsst uns unbedingt auf Instagram folgen
(H: Auch mir folgen!)
Ja natürlich, deswegen habe ich uns ja gesagt!
Weil da entstehen halt auch immer Spoiler und ihr könnt mir da auch immer Vorschläge geben
und natürlich auch hier unten in den Kommentaren.
(H: Und ich esse ja gerne in den Stories und zeige euch das!)
Genau, da gibt's immer Taste Tests! Genau.
Also ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen -nachbacken wollt ich schon fast sagen! -
und bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
Voll die Perfomance, ne? Tschüss!
(H: Warum bist du so zurück gegangen?!)
Ich wollt was Neues einbinden!
(H: *irritiert* Okay, nicht schlimm!)
*kichert*